this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
some said that tending bar but in walks
someone that just looks like they've
seen the light of hell one of the Angry
Birds
Darley that this creature looks
destroyed it looks like he's seen things
that I can't even imagine so I
approached him make him a drink
it doesn't look like he wants a stone
conversation so I don't say anything
that he looks at me and he says what was
it all for
he says the
what was it all for NASA oh you mean the
Angry Bird war you know them on going
against the base of everything
and I save the conclusion that he must
have been a soldier so master mercy if
you don't want me asking I don't know
much about the Angry Bird history how
did all this get started
I said well it all started with the eggs
after the eggs were stolen everything
changed our country changed I mean it
was suddenly like once the eggs
disappear would to be attacked at any
moment who took the eggs was at the
Bates I said now it was like bad I said
the Sun in Finland I said that's the
same one now so I always thought the
whole thing was about the pigs regarding
the pigs
this is that's what the government was
leading you to believe yes the egg man
took the eggs
he took him for himself and yet it was
the paint that got all the play even
though they had nothing to do with it
I did Eggman take the eggs
his name is Eggman
I guess I shall make up oh I want the
pigs get involved bass as well the
government told us that they were
threatening freedom and that I had
strong proof and it was the paints that
took the eggs and not Eggman I even
created video footage they made up lies
they played at the beginning of the game
showing everybody in the world that they
took the eggs so of course everybody
believing it we launched home net
security
they said that we have to spread bird
democracy to them because apparently
they were gonna enrich the eggs you know
make a nuclear weapons of mass nutrition
they called him it was an absolute
Birdemic and of course all the birds
product weathers other animals that have
bigger eggs like ostrich eggs they could
hatch and any woman and let loose even
all dangerous animals I said no the pigs
they're the dangerous ones so we threw
all our birds in the Kamikaze black
birds the white birds with the egg bombs
which is kinda strange for saving a
Explorer using them as weapons anyway we
went all out declared war other things
and how many eggs did we find No
we look through the ruins and there were
no eggs there at all I mean think about
have you ever played that game ever seen
an actual egg have you ever retrieved an
actual egg no you're just killing pigs
Christ there weren't even any secret
kitchens the leader of the pigs you know
the one with the crown we caught him and
we put it on trial he tried to fend
himself saying that we gave him all the
resources they need to run the place
that way but in the end they still
executed her
it was a good bacon some of the best I
ever had he said absolutely delicious
but again he says what's bacon without
eggs
so doesn't that little cannibalistic he
shot me or what can I shut up he said he
lost so many good
and they just don't see what the point
of it is and so I said wow that's must
always something what history west man
so does the water look like it's gonna
wrap up or you're gonna declare war on
the real lightly a sister
I said oh you finally learned your
lesson he says no we just can't afford
it bro
totally broke that's why we did the
tie-in with the movie REO I mean would
anybody have to see that we honestly
attached a name to it unless they were
getting a big sum of money no we need
the moolah so he looks down he looks up
at me again though he says I asked
and also takes he said fucking nights
the joke's on you
he punched me those are other campaing
you see a lot of strange things as a
vault under the wall strange things at
the pixel palace so i'll steal water
streams things as a bartender at the
pizza palace